los contagios en Sudáfrica han aumentado
a velocidades preocupantes desde el
descubrimiento de Omicron se pasó de
poco más de 300 casos diarios a mediados
de noviembre a más de 13000 este jueves
que podemos esperar en términos de
expansión del virus y las cifras cree
ustedes pueden ser un espejo de lo que
podría pasar en América Latina
buenas tardes si lastimosamente
la escalada de contagios en Sudáfrica
llama bastante la atención por dos
razones obviamente por la cantidad de
mutaciones que tiene esta variante pero
también por lo que ha llegado a
desplazar a la variante Delta y
recordemos Delta había desplazado
alfabeta en Sudáfrica entonces llama la
atención que la haya desplazado y en
segundo lugar el alto número de
contagios de test positivos también que
están ocurriendo en Sudáfrica y también
en aguas servidas está encontrando una
alta carga viral de estar con voz bueno
justamente una de las prioridades de
científicas en este momento es entender
que tan alta es la efectividad de las
vacunas actuales contra Omicron y ya las
farmacéuticas se trabajan en preparados
adaptados en caso de ser necesario
porque la importancia de vacunarse hoy
más que nunca
esto es la mejor manera de evitar no
solo contagiarse y contagiar el virus
sino también de llegar a un hospital o
de fallecer por covid-19 a pesar de que
contenta con U con Landa que son otras
variantes que circulado por América las
vacunas han perdido eficacia sobre todo
en contagiarse y contagiar la eficacia
sobre
hospitalizarse decir por desarrollar una
enfermedad grave ha permanecido creemos
que con hombre o micro va a pasar algo
muy similar es decir la eficacia de las
vacunas de contagiarse y contagiar
diminuye pero todavía se va a mantener
cierta protección en relación a
enfermarse o fallece y finalmente quiero
preguntarle qué es lo que hace que
Omicron sea un nuevo reto para la
inmunidad del covid-19 las autoridades
de salud hablan de su capacidad para
evadir la inmunidad previos contagios y
de su mayor riesgo de reinfeccion
fin justamente un reporte que salió el
día de hoy
la inmunidad natural es decir si una
persona se contagio de covid 19 tiene
2.4 veces más probabilidades de
contagiarse si está circulando estaba
abierto micro por ende sobre todo la
inmunidad natural parece que se cierre
esta variante y sus mutaciones parece
que no le hacen tan contagiosa en
relación a Celta pero sí que le hacen
escapar más al sistema inmune entonces
recordemos que Delta contagia más o
menos una persona infectada hasta 6
personas se cree que está variante
contagiar a una persona infectada hasta
6 perdona desde 8 hasta 14 personas
incluso así